a warning this report from our senior
island correspondent david blevins does
contain some flash photography
the goods from great britain were still
rolling in but northern ireland's
devolved government was already on its
way out the dup agriculture minister had
already halted brexit checks but then
the dup first minister resigned today
marks the end of what has been the
privilege of my lifetime their party
leader said the northern ireland
protocol had left them with no option
we've had enough of being told we must
stand by previous agreements yet the
same people who tell us this have
destroyed
a core pillar at the heart of the
belfast agreement the need for cross
community support
in the absence of a functioning
executive an early election must be
called and the people must have their
say
the border between northern ireland and
the republic runs through carlingford
carlingfordlock checks here would be
catastrophic for local fishermen brian's
son only joined the family business
because the eu and british government
had reached agreement
i honestly thought
that
everything was sorted i was
breathed uh sorry relief i'm sixth
generation my oldest son 21 he's seventh
generation and he left school on the
probably i would i let him leave school
he's going to go on to be a physio and a
lap knee skill on the strength of the
protocol
but the alternative has been contentious
a border in the irish sea fueling
loyalist fears over northern ireland's
place in the uk
joel keyes hit the headlines when he
appeared to warn of more violence but he
says his community is misunderstood
there seems to be a habit of kind of
thinking that all unionists are all
loyal or are just crazy hooligans who
run about and screaming about anything
that offends their sense of red white
and blue but that's not really how it
works but if you take my concerns i want
to feel respected and i want my identity
to feel respected in my own country
the eu says brexit checks are enshrined
in international law but the prime
minister disagrees if you look at the
protocol which i'm sure you have studied
in detail
there's plenty about uninterrupted uh
east-west trade it's crazy to have
checks on goods that are basically
circulating within the single market of
the united kingdom
the problem for the prime minister is
that this is not really about trade it's
about politics it's just three months to
the next northern ireland assembly
election and with no end in sight to the
eu uk negotiations on the protocol
brexit's going to dominate the campaign
brexit didn't just raise the question of
checks it raised the age-old question of
where northern ireland's political
future lies
david blevins sky news in belfast